i am actually going to talk about
javascript internationalization uh
there's not a ton that people are doing
on the server side right now because
a lot of that's been figured out a lot
of the libraries well every library that
i'm going to be talking about works in
both places so
um feel free to use any of these modules
or or whatever in in node so javascript
internationalization uh generally
uh manifesting itself as a web app that
you're using uh so yeah that's all
uh so about me or
about this talk
i'm not actually that great of a speaker
but i talk a lot about beautiful
language and so it's kind of a cool
dichotomy
so uh also people think that i can speak
multiple languages because i talk about
translations uh
and i think that's german uh for i don't
uh speak
uh other languages
uh so i i like to uh say that this is a
problem that it's a it's a data problem
it's uh a presentation it's a template
problem like there's
it's not a language necessarily you have
to understand the the
uh restrictions and the
the things that uh
you're set out to solve and you can
solve it without you know knowing a
bunch of languages it helps to know
people who know multiple languages
though it's quite helpful uh so this is
uh less about internationalization
specifically more about user experience
because
really what you're trying to do is is
give users the the best chance to
understand what the heck you're trying
to get them to do
but that
in this case turns out to be
international good internationalization
um so what we're talking about when we
talk about messages and we talk about
internationalization um i'm gonna talk a
lot about the message side of things for
now there's things like uh right to left
and uh and and quite a few things in
internationalization but a lot of uh the
pain that we struggle from these days is
uh is in message formatting and message
displaying uh so so you might not think
that it comes up much or you might think
that it's the same as translating like a
paragraph or something
but it's not so anytime you're mixing
data and a phrase much like you mix data
in a template and out comes the actual
uh you know markup for a page that's uh
that's what we're talking about uh with
messages uh so you want to consider
problems like
there are five results or there are
three new messages or welcome so and so
uh come see why
uh your score is x or you need x more
points to continue things like that
are the types of sentences that are
actually incredibly difficult to
write in a way that work
in every language as much as as you
wouldn't think so
things about me is i like to build
javascript programs um my mom is an
english teacher so there's some
background uh
those are my stats
um i i started out
a blog post called the ux of language
with this tweet and i really like it as
kind of a base um for talking about this
kind of stuff
it's kind of you can tell i favorited it
and
it says web program is the science of
coming up with increasingly complicated
ways of concatenating strings that's
kind of beautiful uh but that's really
what we're talking about and really like
in the end of the day uh if you take
about the javascript like what you see
is just a bunch of concatenated strings
um
so thanks greg brockman for setting me
up
so i'm going to give you a brief history
of string concat
1986 web was for documents so it's
static text files ruled the web uh
obviously no one's running iterm 2 so
that is not the best screenshot
but
either way
there were documents right
and translation was the translation of
documents it was no different than
translation had been in the past
some time passes uh montage video if you
will uh and people desire to customize
content um and this is a huge shift in
the web right it stopped being like look
at this look at this look at this and it
became like here's something for you
uh and so
this was the era of literally just
outputting concatenated strings uh so if
you remember like cgi bin pearl that
kind of stuff like yeah line endings
inside the print statement is awesome um
so uh i think this is like the original
google
uh app
uh so then after that um
crappy templates came around uh uh you
might recognize a language called uh
personal home page or php hypertext
preprocessor or however many
levels deep you want to go uh and and
this is it really was a template
language like they wrote it as a
template language and then just grew and
grew and grew and grew and then uh
later it became like a actual language
kind of
jsp and asp are similar examples of this
just like write your app
and your your code all in the same line
so i used to write these sweet php apps
it was just like the top had like
database access and then it had like the
doctype and then it had some logic for
like if it was a login screen return and
it was awesome it was good it was good
days uh so i call that the nearly 10
years of string concatenation dark ages
and then around 2004 you started seeing
i mean before you saw it but we really
came popular with some of the major nbc
server-side frameworks rails and django
and that kind of stuff uh spring if you
will uh
so logicalist templates came into
popularity they're not necessary but uh
they they became like a good way to
really really decouple
uh you know apps and and html
so like 20 something years later
we can finally render html all right um
so what about rendering a sentence how
is it different so a templated sentence
uh so this is handlebars template i i
tend to like those um uh so this seems
good welcome to the site uh so and so
alex
so we'll try another one uh
hi alex you have blank new messages
seems good
but it's not good because there's a case
especially even in english right so it's
hey alex you have one new messages and
that's bad that's gross uh i believe i
said
uh so this is why this talk uh is is
considered the the ux of language we
want to avoid situations like that and
it gets much much worse whenever you
start
going into other languages that i don't
speak
so our traditional way of concatenating
strings together isn't sufficient
when those strings form a coherent
sentence um
so this is like a rhetorical question
but but uh
this is this is something that i used to
do and i still find myself doing is like
when i make my template i make sure that
even when the template runs like all the
brackets line up nicely in like the
indented way right like so i spend time
doing that uh and then i don't actually
have uh good sentences on my site uh
so uh
this is the sentence we were talking
about earlier
uh you have two new messages um so this
is this is some of the ways that we
solve this
now kind of this is this is our
solutions uh these are our solutions
english uh so the first one's just uh
ugly um
it works in english it doesn't work in
every language if you have more than one
additional way to pluralize something
you'd have to have like some ore
operators in there
it gets bad
and the second one is considered prefix
and postfix sometimes it works but other
times it's still just it's not very
personable
if you consider something like
facebook's application where they say
like alex sexton and three others like
this product
that would be really bad if it was like
people who like this product other than
alex sexton
three
uh
so plural branching uh is is really what
we want to end up doing so let's write
some code to to figure out um
uh
when we want to branch on the two
different strings so in this case you
can you have uh in english right you say
uh if it's one you have one new message
and you have two new messages right uh
and so in spanish uh if you're uh trying
to internationalize your app you have a
branch and you say okay uh now i'll do
this uh
this message in spanish and this message
in english uh and that's cool uh but
this is this is really gross it's
directly coupled inside your app code um
and uh that gets uh really big because
uh here are like some commonly supported
languages um and not all of them just
have two pluralization forms uh
i think i was
feeling uh
i'm sorry uh
so uh so a lot of people immediately say
all right alex like i understand this is
bad i've internationalized an app before
we use get text in our python app or we
use get text here
and i'll get back to that uh that's the
installment picture it's a good comic
but uh i'll get back to to that so so
hold your horses
so navigating the the message landscape
so i'll just go into like some of the
ways people are solving this uh
properties files uh is something that
that often comes up um
they're usually uh
uh just for for internationalization
they're not necessarily for
uh actually like plural forms and things
like that
or gender specific specificity uh
sometimes i'll ask someone uh i like
this metaphor uh someone
what a friend of mine gave me it's like
i'll ask someone do you support
international strings in your
application and they'll say yeah we have
properties files which is the same as
saying
is this tv high definition and someone
saying yes it has pixels
i mean it's not a no
um it's just not a yes either right
uh so it's essentially a set of key
values pairs in this case these
properties files are some objects that i
have um
and
it's good
i forgot how good at spanish i was um
the uh
so so this is all it is and then
whenever you write your application um
it just sticks those strings in so this
is pretty common you'll see it in java
rails
django has this kind of stuff uh pretty
much everybody who's doing translations
you're kind of writing all your messages
in this file you send those off to
translators they send them back and you
switch them out
um so it doesn't really address any of
the hard problems uh with rendering
different strings for different locales
other than it renders one string uh for
for every different locale that's it's
not really uh what we're looking for so
a lot of times people add sprint f so
they'll add one level of indirection uh
and they'll uh they'll put you know the
percent d let's say a number goes here
you have uh blank messages right so uh
that's uh that's the same case um we had
before where you have one messages again
but it's better than nothing so you can
have data in there again but uh you
solve old problems uh but our templates
suck uh now because you have to like
sprint f everything inside of them uh so
we can switch out messages and we can
interpolate data into them kind of like
a template
but they're incorrectly pluralized and
devoid of gender in context that's bad
so authoring templates also starts to
suck because you have all this html and
you have no context of what you're even
talking about you just have these keys
back to properties files and everything
doesn't look like what you expect it to
look like
so we go back to salman and get text
starts to solve some of this stuff po
files are the form
of data exchange that they use there's
like the mozilla poodle project uh for
uh translating and that's p-o-o-t
right so it's
uh it's for po5 it's get text i'm sorry
uh
so it decouples the data message which
was really what we want to do um so they
got a few things really right in get
text
this is like a
json version of maybe what a po file
would look like in json
you give it a locale you give it a
plural form and so this is really
important you say i'm defining my
indexes for my strings
in this plural form and so in english or
enus up here my plural form is if it's
one return a zero and if it's two return
one or if it's anything else return one
uh in in which case you'll grab that
index out of that key so uh if you
notice uh the those indexes match up to
the correct string there and then you'll
run sprint f on it and that's that's
pretty good solution um
so uh
there there's different plural form
functions it's it's kind of a c api
because it was written like in 1970
something
uh this is the english pro form splash
spanish plural form looks exactly the
same french is a little different zero
is kind of like more like none it's it's
uh it's translated along with one uh so
it's that's a singular form kind of uh
slovenian's crazy uh i like this one
because uh
because you have like mod 100
in there at all uh and i i guess that's
the closest uh
the closest thing i can think of to that
is like in english we have uh first
second third and then it's fourth fifth
sixth seventh eighth and then when you
get to like 21st 22nd 23rd it does it
again right and so slovenian like that's
just the way they pluralize everything
uh welsh really sucks too as far as how
many different keywords they have uh
so messages as keys is another
interesting thing that a lot of people
will do at get text so you stick your
whole message in there and you have uh
you have both um you have your default
set in there um directly and so
uh in this case you can see all your
possible messages kind of in line in
there and then they're used as the keys
themselves so then they go back
through the get tech stuff and they can
be switched out so you can kind of see
what will eventually be in there but
also you can still have properties files
or po files
in this case a lot of people will fuzzy
match these so you can like switch out a
comma uh without screwing everything up
but
it's harder in client-side javascript to
fuzzy match things
so uh
there's there's quite a few things that
the features that we can do we can uh
kind of hack gender uh onto the top uh
but but really what i want to get to is
um
you still can't do things like
concatenate two separately translated
strings together that never works so i
like my red uh shirt uh can never work
because
like languages will switch things around
so because you're implying an order by
doing string concatenation you can never
do string concatenation
you have to always
completely translate a full sentence
together
so that's important so we get text we
can pluralize messages
we can interpolate messages and we can
pluralize our message correctly for each
locale so we now have that capacity
we can kind of have templates uh with
the messages inside of them
good enough maybe we can use gender
specific words if we use context for
gender um
and it does it does a pretty good job at
most of the things that we need so git
text is used in the in most linux
projects and ever like tons and tons of
apps use use get text and so it's a
pretty good solution um
uh so so this is
kind of what some of the reasons why you
might use it so uh i wrote jed
uh
and uh i'll probably change the name
soon i'll let you know why uh jed uh is
uh
the
uh mc of the other track he's he up
until a few months ago he was a
translator that was his full-time job he
was just a hobbyist javascripter that
just happened to be better at it than
everyone else
um
i guess when you have a hobby it's
easier to have fun i don't know he's
just good uh so i named it after him
because you don't come across three
character names that often that work
so uh there's i added kind of a
chainable api um for it if you want but
you can also use the old gross c apis um
uh and that was cool so uh why am i not
gonna recommend it um so if we go back
to english we can i can give you a new
sentence a new hard one uh not too
complex uh there are three messages from
two people and so remember you have to
translate uh these all together um and
that's bad because uh get text can only
do one plural so the plural form can
take a single input
so
also
i guess the another problem is if you
have context like you have a menu and
you have a footer you want to use that
for your context not gender so
you can only go one level deep on any of
their features you can pluralize one
thing and you have one context c api is
gross you can fix that
yeah
you also have to repeat plural forms you
can get around some of this uh really
there's quite a bit wrong uh so norbert
lindbergh uh
told me about icu message format uh
whenever i put that out they actually uh
kind of crapped all over it and i was
pretty disappointed but they pointed me
towards icu message format
and really that's just plural format
plus select format ibm i think kind of
runs most icu and they specify things
like
internationalization standards and
things like that there are six keywords
that map to different numbers in every
language different pluralizations uh and
then they'll define plural functions
that map to those words
um
this is the syntax for message format so
it's it's pretty small
and so i wrote an implementation of
message format in javascript and so you
can see he
see here i can switch these out i'm
probably too short on time to do this
very often but i'll do one
you can do that
and then it changes into two messages so
it's a uh it's a grammar for describing
um
uh
internationalization uh and message uh
situations right uh
so um
you can have literals that happen before
uh the the message format things and
those just get sent in
if you don't need multiple language it
doesn't matter you still need to do this
in english right so this is still a very
hard task to do in english because
it's five results in two categories or
one results in two categories or five
results in one category
that gets excessively difficult um and
then you add gender and it's he or she
received five results or one result or
one category or two categories and just
explodes um and in that same case uh you
can do multiple plurals just in the same
sentence it's just two uh separate uh
message format uh
parts uh in the sentence and then you
can nest them uh or you can do select
format for gender uh and you can get he
found five results in two categories and
i can change any of those it'll
automatically output the correct string
you have named arguments so this is just
replacements and things like that you
can add plugins uh this one's highly
readable
what this will do is output every form
of alex added himself and one other
person to his group it's using an offset
plug-in to say alex is included in the
totals but he's not included in the
other person in this group so that's why
the plural amount of people is two but
it's just one person that's there so you
have complex plugins to to do strings
like this and this is like uh straight
out of google's home page or facebook's
google plus all this stuff the only
couple of apps that have decent uh you
know complex translations um it's
translator friendly in the sense that uh
everything's translated together you
don't to translate one sentence that's
directly related to another sentence
completely separately from each other
but it's not translator friendly uh in
that you have to be a programmer to
understand the syntax at all
so that's message format js
it's compilable uh so it takes the input
and pre-compile it out to a raw
javascript function um it uses a parser
expression grammar a lot like isla did
this morning um
generates an ast and then and then spits
out javascript that doesn't even require
the uh original library
so it integrates directly into
handlebars you can write your messages
directly in there it'll it'll pull all
those out compile them it compiles them
just like a template
so a little short on time but uh i just
want to talk about what the next steps
are
tooling
is really what's up next so how do we
use how do we get to use these complex
good solutions for translations and then
actually get our things translated
javascript internationalization is still
in in the in the dark ages so it's
totally possible to write good tools
around these new formats
and so that's why
i'm
open sourcing the jed toolkit which is a
whole family of internationalization
tools both libraries and like
actual web apps
and apis that you can set up in a stack
to help translators uh and do all this
stuff so it's tools and libraries i want
developers to be happy uh i want to kill
like the two month code freeze for the
translation time uh i want to automate
uh sending strings to translators
and
make their translation experience
much better
i have jedtoolkit.org
that you can visit there's a picture of
him we can click on that and then i'll
be done
but i i'd love to to talk oh he's down
there there he is uh so i'd love to talk
about how uh that web app works with a
bunch of people i've been working with
uh some of the major translation
companies
on getting them to be able to use uh
these apps um as their translations uh
kind of spot um because they're still
using tools from like the 70s and word
documents and things like that and ftp
file uploads it's a terrible terrible
world it's like 20 years behind every
other place we are so we can really
really uh bring the tooling for
internationalization up to par with the
tooling that we have for
automated builds and testing and all
that kind of stuff and we'll be in a lot
better place
uh i probably don't have time for
questions i'd guess
maybe one all right one question
do you handle any rtl stuff
rtl i've been saving
uh
the thing with rtl and i had to do one
rtl app
is that so far as i can tell
there's no solution to rtl other than
look at everything individually all by
itself with someone who speaks those
languages a hundred times
like
there
if someone can create something that's
awesome for that i will totally help you
but i don't have that idea yet rtl is
very difficult it's really just like
really pay attention to everything and
and build new code paths luckily
there's no one's going to introduce a
new direction in the next like 20 years
to read code so or read read words so
really yeah just have to deal with the
three that exist uh hopefully only two
really in the real world
good good okay i'm happy to show anyone
the tool uh the translation tool if you
want to it's probably not a good time up
here
so thanks it looks really good so thank
you alex